hop c'est parti salut les djeuns voilà
bio on est content que la vidéo de marc
levy faisait plus aujourd'hui c'est un
peu un concept spécial parce que on
souhaite vous parler d'une chaîne que
probablement vous connaissez pas et qui
pourtant pourrait certainement vous
intéresser l'ess c'est la chaîne de
clotilde chef du site qui s'appelle pas
ces sauvages c'est une chaîne de
vulgarisation d'archéologie
d'anthropologie et d'histoire et on veut
vous en parler aujourd'hui pour lancer
un format sur notre chaîne qui est un
format d'études un peu de l'oeuvre de
youtube heures ça va certainement vous
intéressé parce que c'est effectivement
une chaîne dont on a l'impression que
c'est un peu la même chose que nous mais
dans un autre champ disciplinaire c'est
à dire que c'est un côté un peu
d'analystes est source de chercher à
savoir ce que d'autres gens ont écrit
sur le sujet et d'essayer de recouper un
peu tout ça et d'avancer à petits pas
c'est une chaîne qui est attentive à la
méthode scientifique à la méthodologie
et nous c'est ça qui nous a touchés et
c'est ça qu'on dont on souhaite vous
parler aujourd'hui
yes et on va essayer de réfléchir aussi
avec elle sur ces vidéos et voilà le but
c'est en fait de faire un peu de la
review vidéo mais de réinventer ce
format de review vidéo pour en bas ça
c'est clair
pour ans pour en faire un truc un peu
plus intelligent et où on grandit tous
ensemble quoi bonjour à tous et
bienvenue sur passé sauvage pour ce
premier épisode de la chronique
intitulée la modernité késako le pain
nourrit l'homme depuis la préhistoire
est toujours à la base de repas dans de
nombreux pays c'est quelque chose dont
on connaît les méthodes de fabrication
anciennes et les méthodes et plus
actuelle donc on va pouvoir comparer ces
deux modes de fabrication et voir quel
impact ont eu la modernisation et les
progrès techniques sur le pain au cours
de l'histoire
donc là le pain c'est le fait de dire
qu' on en est venu à un moment où la
production du pain qui est hyper ancien
a commencé à se faire de façon
industrielle et du coup la fabrication
est beaucoup plus simple c'est à dire
que auparavant les gens ils se défoncer
les pièces des français les genoux etc
et d'ailleurs c'était que les familles
et c'est ça qu'elle montre mais qu'
aujourd'hui même si la méthode est
beaucoup plus efficace et ben en fait on
mange un pain qui est beaucoup moins
nutritifs
parce que par l'oxydation du blé tous
les tous les nutriments s'en vont et
donc quand vous achetez votre père en
supermarché et bien moins un nourrisson
qu'il était avant est ce que je trouve
intéressant c'est que
déjà en fait on quand elle sent en 2016
là donc c'est déjà il ya trois ans elle
avait déjà ce truc de faire des vidéos
qui sont en fait des essais c'est à dire
qu'il ya une vraie problématisation du
sujet on n'a pas le risque de l'histoire
de marché seulement par anecdote fait
même s'il ya plein d'anecdotes dans
cette vidéo notamment ce truc de se
rendre compte que étudier les corps c
est aussi et donc par exemple aidant
c'est aussi étudié finalement on déduire
les modes de production du pain c'est
quand même assez dingue en date des
anecdotes mais a montré une vraie
problématisation et mais le truc ça
c'est qu'on voit pas trop je trouve dans
c'est dans cette première vidéo encore
où nous mène cette question pour
l'instant en tout cas la conclusion lé
pas encore net
on sait qu'on a appris des choses mais
on sait pas où on en est arrivé quoi
peut-être que c'est pour donner envie de
voir la suite
peut-être regard la suivante allez
aujourd'hui je vous propose d'examiner
la question de la modernité à travers
notre façon de se loger en prenant comme
exemple la maison la façon dont on
construit est très révélatrice de ce
qu'on considère comme moderne
en effet la maison évoque l'intimité
l'aspect familial et aussi la façon dont
une société s'organise
c'est le site de pansements en cinéma il
ya treize mille ans des chasseurs
magdaléniens avait coutume d'y séjourner
durant l'automne au centre du campement
sont implantés les ateliers de taille de
silex pour hommes femmes enfants à
proximité de chaque poste un accès au
feu pour le confort des tailleurs des
tapis peaux de rennes sous placées au
sol
on n'a pas oublié les zones de tri
sélectif déjà à l'époque les habitations
familiales sont placés non loin de la
zone de travail pour plus de proximité
et afin d'éviter les temps de trajet il
ya même un atelier destiné aux leçons de
taille pour les plus jeunes
sorte de garderie préhistorique si vous
voulez well en fait on se rend compte de
ce qui était première déjà dans la
première vidéo
c'est ce travail sur l' indice en fait
c'est dans la démarche scientifique de
l'historien et l'idée qu'on a des traces
et c'est l'idée c'est de décrypter la
trace est d'essayer de proposer des
hypothèses à partir des traces fonda et
ça c'est ce qui est mis en avant de
façon passionnante je trouve comment est
ce que à partir des dents
de l'homme préhistorique ou à partir par
exemple à de son habitat on va essayer
de décrire une société c'est finalement
l'idée dira oui la vidéo d'histoire elle
me donne le goût de l'histoire et le
goût de l'histoire comme science comme
enquête
exactement comme après cela c'est la
méthode historique qui nous est présenté
et sans forcément qui est un discours
d'ailleurs sur cette méthode pour
l'instant en tout cas
mais on nous montre comment est ce qu'on
fait de l'histoire et ça joue ça trop
bien est une autre chose aussi on nous
montre aussi comment faire de l'histoire
avec des sources et ça aussi ça fait
partie complètement de la méthode
historique quoi en france les zones
pression ils se sont installés par
exemple dans la grotte du lazaret à
proximité nice en 150 milles avant notre
ère les vestiges nous montrent qu'ils
n'occupaient pas la totalité de l'espace
etc au moyen de pierre il avait délimité
une zone domestique dans la grotte
il ya donc une volonté de créer un
espace à part dans la grotte en
l'aménageant et en créant peut-être même
une intimité c'est bien présent cette
construction de l'espace dans l'espace
naturel ça est vachement penser aux
travaux toutes les questions autour de
la plage c'est à la plage et à l'espace
naturel tout le monde se partage et
chacun va les définir son espace
d'intimité avec sa serviette et en gros
ce qui est intéressant c'est que tout le
monde accepte complètement cette norme
un peu étrange que quand il ya une
serviette et ben c'est chez toi c'est un
des seuls endroits en fait on ne peut se
coller à quelqu'un et avoir l'impression
complètement des dans un espace intime
donc on commence à tout a changé et
c'est ya pas de problème est en fait vu
qu'il a le petit centimètre deux plages
qui va bien et qui est la serviette et
bah c'est bon et le parasol bien venir
finir de clôturer cet espace intime quoi
oui et ce qu'on retrouve longue c'est
chez toi
exactement tu peux être tranquille il
peut regarder des vidéos de ma fille
carlitos ans conduit exactement où dire
dumarquez vie et voilà et donc il ya ce
truc là qui est hyper intéressant c'est
que on retrouve un peu cette
construction l'espace intime et où que
ce qui est intéressant aussi voit dans
cette vidéo c'est que ça montre le
finalement une continuité entre
préhistoire et l'histoire alors même que
nos imaginaires de représentation
viendrai inscrire une rupture hyper
forte avec un imaginaire qui s'est
construit après comme on verra dans
d'autres vidéos mais après c'est vrai
que d'une certaine manière il ya une
problématisation permanente est
vachement pertinentes qui est le fait de
dire simplement que 90% des choses que
on sait par sens commun de la
préhistoire et faut en fait les exemples
archéologiques nous montre que les
hommes préhistoriques envisager leur
lieu de vie de façon globale
et c'est bien cette notion de globalité
de concevoir sa maison en pensant à ce
qui se trouve autour qui est une
démarche que l'on peut qualifier de
moderne la question la modernité le
problème c'est que c'est un terme qui
est extrêmement polémique en fait et qui
aussi qu'impose l'idée du progrès et ça
c'est extrêmement important dans la
pensée de passer sauvage
il n'y a pas si longtemps j'ai vu une
frise chronologique ou qui s'étalait
depuis peut-être un peu plus de 2
millions quoi et où on renseigner toutes
les inventions de truc c'est à dire
qu'on disait machin telle date
invention de trucs mais tu te dis mais
du coup c'est super parce que plus on
avance plus on invente de chose à te
dire et c'est hyper bizarre parce qu'il
aurait aussi pu mettre telle date
oubli de tel truc tu vois pas dire à un
moment et donc on sait bien quand les
gens disent c'était mieux avant qu'en
fait ils négligent énormément de choses
mais d'une certaine manière l'extrême
inverse est tout aussi absurde
exactement la maison moderne
d'aujourd'hui est inventé alors que la
maison moderne du néolithique a été
inventé en fait le problème du terme de
modernité c'est que il contient une
connotation axiologique dresse devant la
modernité il y a le mot mieux c'est faux
il n'ya pas de moi de mieux dans
modernité mais vous ai compris des liens
m en tout cas oui mais d'ailleurs ça me
fait penser à une vidéo dans cette vidéo
cro magnon toi même elle montre bien que
l'homme d'après nous il est pas si
anciens et qu'en fait il ne ressemble
vachement et que si on croisait dans la
rue on le distingue a pas forcément et
donc on se sert de ce nom là pour info
les dix qualifiés sans forcément se
rendre compte que encore une fois si tu
étais hommes de cro magnon et ben je le
verrais pas sauf à la fin 128 marches
c'est marrant parce que j'ai
l'impression que ça fait partie des
des concepts guerrier dans les termes de
karl schmidt quoi de dire c'est pas du
tout un concept qui a qui véhicule un
sens par lui même
c'est juste un concept qui est utilisé
dans une guerre voilà pour contrer
autrui c'est une guerre linguistique est
une guerre de deux représentations de
guerre symbolique coin qui est de dire
que cro magnon ne veut rien dire
hormis que goethe affuble de ce nom là
pour te dis pour te discréditer pour
dire tu es vraiment un sauvage etc
comme il ya eu pendant longtemps la même
chose avec le moyen-âge et d'ailleurs il
ya un il ya un regain qui est hyper
hyper enthousiasmant quoi sur toutes ces
périodes là de dire mais enfin pose en
une deux secondes et regarder quoi
regarder ce qu'ils ont fait regarder
toutes les choses qui savait faire c'est
pas de dire qu'ils avaient tout compris
et que nous on est des bleus au mais
voilà c'est d'essayer d'aplanir un peu
et les redescendre de son piédestal
absurde quoi je veux dire on s'est quand
même répétée des bombes atomiques sur la
gueule et c'est vraiment ce qui est
marrant d'ailleurs puisque donc voilà je
suis sûr que ces sites est en permanence
mais c'est le truc de
lévi strauss dans cette histoire qui est
quand même assez connu cette phrase qui
dit le barbare c'est d'abord celui qui
croit à la barbarie c'est le fait de
dire que c'est pas un concept
intéressant pour réfléchir à ces
périodes là bas on regarde cette
première vidéo acheter la l'île de bric
et de broc
il ya des villes qu'on identifie à coup
sûr un coup d'oeil rapide sur un
bâtiment au style architectural bien
prononcé et on peut facilement dire
paris londres bruxelles prague
alors c'est vrai pour certaines villes
mais évidemment pas pour toutes car les
images que je viens de vous montrer
elles proviennent d'une seule et même
ville à savoir lille d'abord sa part
d'une problématique immédiate qui est de
dire cette ville a priori n'a aucune
unité architecturale
c'est très divers quoi et donc pourquoi
et je trouve que c'est très agréable
pour le spectateur de d'être emmenés par
distinction conceptuel c'est à dire de
dire c'est certes une ville industrielle
mais avant tout parce que c'est une
ville d'industriels et donc c'est parce
que il ya du coup des riches patrons
d'entreprises qui se font construire des
maisons dans le centre historique et
qu'ensuite la main d'oeuvre si je peux
dire travaille aussi dans la même ville
et habite la ville mais du coup pas du
tout les mêmes quartiers et ska est
frappant c'est que du coup toute cette
histoire par exemple avec notre dame qui
a brûlé la question de savoir comment
est-ce qu'on reconstruit voilà on voit
bien que du coup à cause des guerres et
de toutes les bombes qui sont tombées et
ben ils ont décidé de reconstruire à
l'identique ce qui est pas du tout
anodin comme question parce que
reconstruire à l'identique ça fait un
peu de ta ville un musée c'est à dire
qu'on dit je veux absolument que ça
continue de ressembler que ça reste un
témoin de l'histoire et non plus
forcément un lieu où habitent et de
façon très agréable c'est à dire que
l'on cherche pas à moderniser un niveau
de confort ou chat pas quoi on dit
simplement il faut que ça reste la même
chose et donc du coup on reste du côté
du musée plutôt que du côté de la maison
et c'est pour ça je pense que ça permet
d'introduire de façon intéressante les
problématiques delà de l'histoire de
l'architecturé c'est que c'est justement
là que a commencé mallet stevens le gars
qui fait la première
villa fonctionnaliste et ce qui est
intéressant aussi c'est à porter l'idée
que la ville qui a l'air d'être faite de
bric et de broc
en fait elle est surtout faite en
contraste c'est à dire que ces volontés
en fait cette impression qu'on peut
avoir deux voilà de diversité en fait
c'est complètement volontaire parce
qu'il a le désir de s'opposer
brutalement à la dimension fonctionnelle
quoi enfin chose que je trouve
intéressant c'est que finalement à la
fin de la vidéo on conclut complètement
sur justement une vraie conclusion qui
est très complexe comme on abat comme on
a pu en parler c'est très compliqué
justement sur ce genre de vidéos hulu
demande de dresser un peu un panorama
des de la diversité d'une ville
finalement de mettre en avant les
problématiques du contraste et pourquoi
il ya ce contraste etc
le fait de voir quand il était voilà ce
contraste il est issu d'un dialogue
entre différentes générations entre
différentes cultures entre aussi d'un
dialogue mais aussi d'un rapport de
force parfois entre différentes couches
de la société
et de conclure en fait vise justement
sur une réponse à cette question de
pourquoi ce contraste c'est super fort
et en fait il y ait beaucoup de youtube
heure ou deux documentaristes qui ont
beaucoup de mal justement à donner tout
à la fin cet aperçu de bad une réponse
en fait un objet qui ont été posées on
pense aux mêmes imagine pas faire de
l'histoire ce n'est pas forcément
retenir des dates parker visiter des
abbayes cisterciennes et arpenter les
rayons bibliothèque
il ya de ça oui mais pas que la
connaissance a besoin de l'émotion qui
est attaché au lieu et il faut pour la
ressentir s'y rendre physiquement
pompéi est une cité romaine antique
située en campanie à quelques kilomètres
au sud de naples l'archéologie n'est de
la découverte ou plutôt de la re
découverte de pompéi ce site
archéologique constitue au fil des
années un laboratoire où on élabore des
techniques de fouille le site des moyens
de conservation et de restauration
si la cité a disparu en 79 sa mise au
jour et son ouverture au public depuis
le xviiie siècle signe sa seconde monde
les vestiges et en particulier les
fresques murales sont endommagés à
mesure que les touristes affluent sur le
site
ce processus de dégradation qui couvrent
d'un étrange voile blanc et les
peintures des villas autrefois éclatante
est certes progressif mais inévitable
yes magot trop bonne vidéo
ouais moi ça m'a beaucoup plu aussi
cette vidéo passé sauvage elle l'a fait
en collaboration avec notre ami le
militaire qui lui aussi a fait une vidéo
sur ton pays et surtout l'imaginaire et
toute la façon qu'il y avait eu de
raconter un peu cette ville cette ville
fantôme quoi et donc je trouve que ça
montre quelque chose de passionnant qui
est vraiment l'idée de dire que
l'archéologie c'est pas forcément une
conceptualisations a priori des fouilles
mais c'est plutôt tout talent tout
l'ensemble par expérience des méthodes
mises en place à partir de pompéi donc
1862 dire quelle est la meilleure façon
directement sur le chantier de déblayer
les trucs de pouvoir un peu mettre au
jour ses ruines là pour non seulement au
mieux les préserver
et en plus d'essayer de restituer un peu
la façon dont les choses se passent et
vraiment c'est la méthode scientifique
parce que c'est par tentative paraissait
etc l'archéologie
un peu comme la physique quantique
finalement à ce truc la 2d quel regard
de son objet et ben en fait elle le
détruit l autre qu à l alter et le
modifie et donc c'est un vrai dilemme
qui est présenté dans la vidéo de voir
comment est-ce qu'on peut ou jusqu où
est-ce qu'on peut regarder quelque chose
et jusqu'au en fait il faut parfois ne
pas travailler sur un objet est épargné
un objet en fait pour le futur parce que
plus tard on le regardera peut-être
mieux
oui c'est ça parce qu'elle dit à un
moment dans la vidéo qu'ils estiment que
trois cinquième seulement de la ville
exhumé et que les archéologues ont fait
le choix de ne pas exhumer le reste pour
ne pas trop la mi mai et pour peut-être
que les archéologues du futur qui auront
peut-être des meilleures méthodes qui
sait eh ben et encore des choses à
exhumer pour eux pour leurs témoignages
ce qui est passionnant dans cette vidéo
c'est qu'il ya aussi une réflexion sur
la transmission une bonne transmission
c'est une transmission qui passe par une
expérience et l'expérience naturellement
en fait elle va altérer elle va me
soulier finalement le matériau initial
quoi et ça qui est hyper frustrant pour
le scientifique
c'est pour ça que scientifique et
vulgarisateur ont un rapport qui est
toujours problématique ou toujours à
l'interroger toujours en tension c'est
pas la source n'est pas sous la même
forme au moment où elle est transmise au
moment où il est créé au moment où elle
est transmise est une des choses
intéressantes dans la réflexion de taxer
sauvage c'est justement de ceux de se
demander comment arriver à offrir une
expérience et le dira comme un cadeau
sans trahir la méthodologie extrêmement
rigoureuse extrêmement et en notant
puissante la méthodologie scientifique
et ce qui est intéressant je trouve
c'est qu'elle fait de la méthode
scientifique un voyage donc voilà on a
fait un peu l'historique de la chaîne on
est remonté dia trois ans jusqu'à
l'année dernière
et puis là les dernières vidéos on va
pas en parler en fait on va vous laisser
le découvrir enfin on va les brosser
rapidement donc il ya les vidéos qu'elle
a fait sur le procès klaus barbie c'est
un type un procureur du tribunal de lyon
maquis qui raconte le truc il parle
extrêmement bien et en plus ça s'est
passé dans les années 80 tout a été
filmé et c'est enfin c'est un document
d'archivé à nouveau qui est absolument
passionnant parce que sauvage vous
l'avez aussi sans doute vu passer du
fait de sa collaboration avec le vortex
qui est un truc financé par arte et où
en fait ils ont essayé de penser un
genre d'univers étendue de la
vulgarisation comme si plusieurs
vulgarisateur habitait dans la même
maison
ce qui me fait pas rêver du tout mais
bon bref en tout cas dans la vidéo ça
marche bien et où il discute un peu les
uns avec les autres et je trouve que
c'est très bien fait c'est à dire que
vraiment on voit la mesure dans laquelle
des disciplines diverses que
habituellement on pense franchement
enclose en fait se complètent et je
trouve ça très bien fait chez moi j'ai
regardé toutes les vidéos ça je trouve
que la vulgarisation aujourd'hui toute
façon c'est c'est compliqué vous voyez
bien nous on change de format tous les
quatre matins et je trouve que eux ils
le font très bien
elle un tipi aussi vous voyez
tipi c'est un site où les gens peuvent
ou les abonnés peuvent faire des dons
ponctuels ou réguliers aux gens dont il
aime le travail
c'est vrai que ça fait partie en fait
des sources de financement principale
pour pas mal de gens parce que c'est
quelque chose qui permet en étant un peu
régulier de voilà de permettre d'avancer
et surtout de pouvoir traiter des sujets
qui sont pas forcément des commandes par
exemple nous marc levy je pense que
personne ne leur a commandé on avait
écrit d'ailleurs pour avoir des services
de presse à robert laffont je crois
qu'ils en avaient rien à [ __ ] et puis
n'ont même pas répondu ouais
s'excuserait pas répondu ok ouais c'est
vu mais non et donc voilà et je trouve
que pour que voilà la recherche avance
parfois eh bien il faut qu'elle se
perdent un peu qu'elles se disent tiens
mais pourquoi est-ce que je parlerai pas
de ça est en fait en travaillant et ben
on met au jour quelque chose
d'intéressant et je trouve que les tipis
c'est vraiment quelque chose de chouette
ben ouais l'intérêt aussi tipi c'est le
diversifié aussi mine de rien les les
sources de financement parce que tipi
c'est une source diverses en soi mais
ton n'est qu'il ya plein de petits
donateurs et c'est l'intérêt aussi du
micro mais senna c'est qu'en fait on n'a
pas un seul donateur qui le dit allez
tiens je te file tout ton salaire et
puis et intérêts faire ce que je veux il
ya tout un tas de personnes qui nous
aident pour tout un tas de raisons
différentes
et en fait ça permet aussi d'avoir une
certaine sécurité en fait de dire bah
ouais c'est vrai le mois prochain si je
sors une vidéo et bah je vais pouvoir
avoir un jeu pour avoir un boudin un
bout de salaire on va dire qui va me
permettre d'un bout de vivre quoi en
tout cas elle aperçut convient de vous
donner j'ai déjà dit mais c'est vraiment
un aperçu des surtout des premières
parties de ses vidéos d'un meeting voilà
et l'idée c'est de résister pas aller
jeter un coup d'oeil à voir vous abonner
voir regarder toutes les vidéos surtout
les récentes puisqu'on en a pas du tout
parlé ou presque pas et justement c'est
l'idée c'est justement de montrer dans
cette vidéo la de tracer un peu
l'itinéraire et l'évolution de s'arrête
de la réflexion qu'elle ait eus on
espère que ça a été assez pertinent et
nous aussi en fait de permettre de
réfléchir
nous aussi voilà avec vous votre propre
idée sur notre propre démarche
et c'est ça aussi qui nous importe c'est
que les vidéos souvent si jamais on les
regarde juste sur youtube elles ont une
durée de vie hyper courte on reste un
peu dans la consommation alors que si
jamais on essaie de les faire sortir de
youtube et de les données de les
utiliser un peu comme comme comme
nourriture de discussions et de
réflexions et ben je pense que c'est
vraiment quelque chose d'important et
qu'il nous faut qu'il nous fait sortir
un peu de la voilà du flux tendu et
d'ailleurs on voit bien que à partir du
moment où on se retrouve sur la page de
d'un vidéaste ou d'une vidéaste et ben
on sort aussi du fait que c'est
l'algorithme qui nous envoie mois après
mois ou une vidéo en disant tiens
pourquoi pas mais quand on essaie de
voir un peu verticalement la
l'itinéraire d'une personne et va on se
rend compte qu'en fait il y a voilà une
volonté docteur qui se manifeste et et
qui montre et qui éclaire un peu le
parti pris sur différentes différentes
vidéos
ouais finalement une chaîne youtube
c'est un peu comme la ville de lille
qu'on a pu voir dans la vidéo l'île de
bric et de broc c'est que c'est c'est
fait on a l'impression que ces faits de
bric et de broc quand on regarde cette
chaîne là avec nous il ya finalement pas
un format qui se ressemblent quoi et en
fait c'est enfermer est en fait en reste
et c'est dubé deux fois mais parce que
c'est faible parce que c'est un dialogue
en fait c'est une évolution avec tout un
tas de volonté dont vie de du projet
dangereux et ses complexes qui ce qui se
crée et le but c'est de mettre au jour
justement cette vision donc c'est la fin
de cette vidéo on espère qu'elle vous a
plu c'était la première fois qu'on le
faisait on verra bien en fonction des
retours de savoir un peu comment
améliorer cette chose là parce qu'il ya
d'autres chaînes dont on aimerait parler
et dont on pense qu'elle pourrait vous
intéresser parce que on a un peu
l'impression de saisir qui est notre
public quoi des gens qui ont à peu près
notre âge un peu plus âgés pas forcément
et aimée qui mais qui aime les choses un
peu solides moi-même même quand elles
prennent leur temps et ça c'est la
raison pour laquelle on pense que ça
vous plaira alors dites-nous ce que vous
en pensez ça nous intéresse énormément
et puis en attendant voilà
la cloche pouces bleu des piliers de cet
état yes à bientôt
[Musique]